[Music]
this isn't computer animation or a trick
of the light a wood-carved city actually
just popped out of that chunk of a trees
and they can pop right back in so what's
going on Hardesty Lee Carter works with
a totally unexpected form of art that
requires a tough to navigate canvas he
uses burles these bulbous and kind of
gross growths found on the side of trees
look inside them and you'll see amazing
swirling patterns but when he looks
inside he sees an opportunity to create
a pop-up city that could take him hours
to meticulously carve but that he can
play with for a lifetime whoo these
pieces appear right before your eyes but
also disappear in an instant that's
because the carvings work like an
extendable telescope so how exactly does
he carve such intricate castles into a
tree trunk and how exactly do they work
he chooses to use burles because each of
them have a natural edge that's unique
making hpc makes one-of-a-kind luli
carves into those natural edges using
different types of saws he does most of
his cutting with a scroll saw the trick
to getting his pieces just right is to
cut into the wood at a slight angle this
way the pieces are able to move around
without flying right out this also means
each level the castle will fit inside
the one underneath it creating a
telescopic effect the castles will be
able to expand out and collapse back
into each other I have to be very
careful especially if it's a bigger
piece and often I stand at my sprawl so
I feel my heart pounding knowing I
cannot mess up otherwise everything to
lose the piece he maps out where he'll
place all the hidden doors and windows
before he starts cutting then he takes
each individual level of the castle out
and drills holes where all the details
will go
this way he can place them directly
under the scroll saw in order to make
perfect cuts since I'm a designer's
vault there has to be a certain distance
between the different sections so I
intuitively have to guess that angle the
hardest part of Alize process though
getting the angles just right because
the density of the raw wood he uses
differs he has to approach each piece
differently getting those angles right
every time has taken him years of
practice two decades and more of scroll
sawing allowed me to refine a technique
and push it further he totally changed
my life after everything is cut he adds
the final finishing touches and sands
the piece then it's completed with
finishing oil for the past couple of
years
boolie has been selling his castles at
the Portland Saturday market every
weekend his favorite part watching
people react to his work